okay let's go to another caller geez it
is things are fired up today okay who
else did I want to go to oh okay let me
go to our caller from the to14 area code
who's calling today from two one four
it's me Chris hey Chris what's up you're
not on speakerphone right hello Chris
all right good good so I guess what I'm
wondering about David after this whole
election these whole elections I don't
think there's really a path to victory
for for Bernie at all I mean I'm kind of
disappointed about it because of like
the student loan debt and the healthcare
crisis that we have right now yep well
what I'm really more worried about is I
don't think Biden really has much of a
chance to beat Trump okay I'm kind of
like like what you said was like that
prior conversation that you had before
as well I don't think he has much of a
chance to beat him especially in states
like New Hampshire
you don't think Biden will beat Trump in
New Hampshire I'm just looking at the
primary results for New Hampshire where
Trumbull almost got 200,000 votes and
Joe Biden was like in a distant fourth
oh okay I mean listen New Hampshire
rarely decides an election but here's my
view on this okay I get a lot of people
that call me and they say David Onley
Bernie can beat Trump only Tulsi can
beat Trump only Andrew yang can beat
Trump whatever
I think 80% of the November outcome is
going to be the circumstances on the
ground at the time if the economy is
perceived as being pretty good if the
virus is under control it is very
difficult to remove an incumbent
president historically it's really tough
to knock out an incumbent president I
think both Biden and Bernie would
struggle to win in that case if the
economy is not perceived as good if
Trump's approval rating drops into the
mid 30s if the virus is continuing to
spread I think either Bernie or Biden
would have a very good shot at defeating
Donald Trump this black/white stuff
about only this this person would
definitely lose this person would
definitely when I'm not seeing any data
that backs it up yeah because I guess I
was also worried about others swing
states like Florida as well I think
Biden has I definitely think Biden has a
chance in Pennsylvania because that's
where his home state is and he'll have
the home state advantage but I think
Trump also has an advantage in Florida
as well yeah it's just we listen Bernie
does terribly in Florida Florida
Democrats like Biden way better than
they like Bernie in the general you
obviously need to pull in Independence
and some Republicans I don't know the
answer about Florida at this point but I
think the black/white thinking about
this Democrat would definitely win in
this Democrat would definitely lose the
candidate once you're down to just a
couple people like we have now is only
about 15 to 20 percent of the outcome
80% is going to be when you're looking
at reelecting a president it's going to
be what is the perception of how the
country is doing at the time please you
really do think if the corona virus is
still out of control Biden Biden may
actually have a chance of beating Trump
that and as a result and if the economy
is terrible yes I do believe I do
believe that and just as easily it could
be the opposite and the same would apply
to Bernie so what are other states that
these things are going to be on the
radar because I'm thinking about states
like Florida States it's gonna it's
gonna come down to what happens in
Michigan Pennsylvania North Carolina
Wisconsin the states that that made made
the decision back in 2016 all right
thank you we're gonna do the story I
state more upcoming let me take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because I will go right back to the
phones just after this privacy calm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
privacy's of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone instead of
exposing your real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want I especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number because I can destroy the
virtual card number as soon as I give it
to the company and I know I won't be
charged in the future if you're ordering
food over the phone why do I need to
give a restaurant my real card number I
don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are your real credit card
number is protected from the data
breaches that happen unfortunately more
often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman